with almost 500 men t18 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see from
lobster tables we had to store your data
then stay tuned because here is the
rewind with all the choices available
choosing the right storage or database
system for your existing or new
applications can be hard in their talk
Dave nettleton and Robert Saxby walk you
through Google's cloud offerings and
help you make decisions for the right
storage services to use for your use
cases starting with a short
retrospective on how a storing of bits
and bytes evolved over time Dave
explains key features of each product
from cloud memory store to cloud file
store driven by different workload
requirements each product is used in
different ways and various industries so
no matter if you are building games and
need a fast manage dictionary with cloud
memory store for sub-millisecond key
value lookups or if you're running your
SAS platform in retail and e-commerce
and need a fully managed relational
database with cloud SQL and when your
business happens to grow like there's no
tomorrow
you will need a horizontally scalable
relational database but nowhere we have
you covered here with cloud spanner
of course not all applications requires
the skimmers and relational semantics
many times flexibility is more important
to move fast and innovate our scalable
document database cloud fire store has
you covered here with integration into
firebase platform you can build your
next highly scalable mobile application
which synchronize the state across
multiple devices for millions of
concurrent users seamlessly now to make
your applications better behind the
scenes understanding how your products
are used is key cloud big table with its
reads and writes in single digital
millisecond range and HBase
compatibility will help you drive your
real-time analytics to new levels and if
you need a massively scalable paper use
OLAP data warehouse that speaks SQL and
can create petabytes of data in minutes
then bigquery will be your best friend
but let's not forget your videos music
images or for that matter any kind of
blobs all those go into planets ka-plop
storage cloud storage where you can
Optim
for cost and excess frequency without
changing api's to store bits and bytes
closer to your EMS we offer persistent
disks in various shapes and sizes
spinning or solid-state flexibly
attached to your virtual machines or
even closer next to your processors with
local SSDs we are almost there there's
one more storage salutant fresh from the
press if you need fast file access from
multiple machines for example distribute
jobs through a managed network file
system up to 64 terabytes and 30 K read
eye ops then check out our newly added
family member cloud file store yes cloud
file store the L is important here to
round out the session Roberts xB talks
about best practices and common
architecture patterns for data storage
and analytics in short separate your
compute and storage and you'll do great
if this worked your interest please
watch the full talk links are in the
description below don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more create next to Ryan content
thank you for watching
you
[Music]